i can't breathe ich kann nicht atmen
das waren seine mehrfach wiederholten
letzten worte bevor george durch einen
offensichtlich völlig überzogenen
polizeieinsatz in minneapolis starb
seitdem sind die usa in aufruhr gewalt
erzeugt gegengewalt und der präsident
sieht massive kritik auf sich
usa in aufruhr scheitert oder profitiert
trump jetzt in der phoenix runde
[Musik]
phoenix runde
herzlich willkommen bei uns liebe
zuschauer meine gäste zunächst hier im
studio frau professor christiane lemke
politikwissenschaftlerin an der leibniz
universität in hannover und zu lehren
auch an universitäten in den vereinigten
staaten georgia an bord ist bei uns
beirat von republiken seven seas das ist
die auslandsorganisation der
republikanischen partei der usa der ja
donald trump auch angehört sie sind
immobilien unternehmer in usa und
deutschland und auch von früher kennen
sie quasi donald trump als
berufskollegen aus münchen zugeschaltet
ist ron williams kam in den 1960 er
jahren als sie nach deutschland und hat
sich hier als schauspieler und
entertainer einen namen gemacht viele
kennen ihn für sein engagement gegen
rassismus wurde er 2004 vom
bundespräsidenten mit dem
bundesverdienstkreuz ausgezeichnet und
per skype dabei aus dem urlaub
zugeschaltet etwas weiter weg von berlin
ansgar graw herausgeber des debatten
magazins european von 2009 bis 2017 also
acht jahre lang korrespondent für die
welt in washington
rheinberg machen die usa in ihrer
außenwirkung gerade eine gute figur
also mit sicherheit nicht das ist eine
schreckliche geschichte was da passiert
ist und ich kann nur den präsidenten
zitieren was er gesagt hat also die
bilder gesehen hat er hat einfach gesagt
das ist halt das ist schrecklich das
kann man gar nicht anschauen
das ist eine katastrophe wenn es einen
drittel der us amerikaner unterstützt
nach umfragen uneingeschränkt donald
trump wahrscheinlich die zahl der
sympathisanten sogar noch ein bisschen
höher
das ist zahlenmäßig eine starke
minderheit die den präsidenten stützt
das muss man auch immer in rechnung
stellen wenn man sich die situation in
usa ansieht ja kann man aber man muss
auch feststellen dass zurzeit seine
polen wenn man es denn sehr sehr schwach
der demokratische auf herausforderer
führt in aller 50 bundesstaaten im
moment und ich muss sagen was mein
landsmann jetzt gerade von sich gegeben
hat dass der präsident sich das als
vorspann geschichte er redet viel und
sagt wenig ich nehme nichts ab was er
sagt sondern es ist einfach top daria
werbowy das haus gut dann frau lemke der
ein wahlsieg von trump der ist ja
keineswegs ausgeschlossen auch wenn wir
wollen williams gerade sagt die umfragen
etwas anders sagen wir mal wieder die
wahlen gewinnen nicht die umfragen und
der wahlsieg trotz oder gerade wegen
seiner haltung zu den protesten macht er
den aus seiner sicht im moment alles
richtig donald trump also ist natürlich
eine ganz komplizierte situation weil er
hat mit der korona krise zu kämpfen und
da hat er sehr schlechtes management
geleistet hat viel kritik geerntet
gerade von den gouverneuren auch viele
fragen und wünsche offen gelassen und
jetzt eben diese brutale polizeigewalt
auf die er meines erachtens auch nicht
wirklich sehr klug reagiert hat denn er
versucht jetzt durch stärke durch
diskussionen das militär einzusetzen
seine autorität wieder herzustellen und
ich glaube das ist ein falscher weg
ich glaube dass er im moment viel
kapital verspielt
ansgar graw mit blick aufs tram gibt es
ja auch hierzulande so eine art freund
feind schema wird das eigentlich der
situation den usa gerecht dass wir so
nach dem prinzip gut gehe auf die usa
gucken
nein das wird sicherlich nicht der
situation gerecht wir müssen schon sehr
darauf achten dass trump in der tat am
anfang also noch in cape canaveral war
durchaus sehr mitfühlende worte für die
familie des getöteten
gefunden hat ich glaube ja danach die
großen fehler gemacht er hat danach
nicht das thema polizeibrutalität und
die gibt es ja als phänomen durchaus das
hat er nicht thematisiert das aber nicht
angesprochen dass er da nicht verurteilt
sondern er hat quasi wer diesen fall von
george freut als ein einzelfall
dargestellt dass ich würde auch nicht
behaupten dass es ein massenphänomen ist
es sterben mehr weiße aber es gibt auch
mehr weiße verbrecher als vater aber ja
durch polizeigewalt als staat dadurch
sterben nur ich habe diese diese diese
tragweite dass man sich um das phänomen
als solches kümmern muss das hat trump
wie so oft er auch diesmal liegen dass
ich würde noch hinzufügen wollen vierter
beiden ist die situation auch nicht so
einfach im moment verliert zwar der
präsident weiter an ansehen und trat
nicht nur eben in deutschland wo er
sowieso auf einen sehr niedrigem
ansehens niveau stand sondern auch in
den usa aber auch vor beiden kann sich
im moment ist angewiesen auf die stimmen
der schwarzen wenn er gewinnen will
braucht er ein großer ein große
wahlbeteiligung der schwarzen und er
braucht ihre stimmen und er kann sich
aber moment nicht zu sehr mit den
schwarzen identifizieren weil das die
amerikanische öffentlichkeit zwischen
den friedlichen protesten denen man jede
moralische integrität zu recht zuspricht
und den gewaltsamen proteste die für das
chaos sorgen für die randale sorgen dass
schwer zu unterscheiden das heißt wenn
sich joe biden zu sehr auf die seite der
protestler erstellt dann könnte das von
vielen seiner grundsätzlichen
sympathisanten empfunden werden als
jemand der auch mit den lions mit denen
mit den unruhen mit dem kanal
signalisiert da muss also auch schon
beiden aufpassen dass es nicht für ihn
so ein
ich würde gerne nochmal nachher auf den
wahlkampf eingehen aber vielleicht dass
wir ganz kurz noch bei den ron williams
bei den protesten bleiben die wir da
gerade sehen
haben sie eine vorstellung wohin das
noch führen könnte könnten die
möglicherweise noch weiter entkleiden
noch sich weiter zuspitzen was könnte da
den usa noch bevorstehen
ich fürchte dass das genau das ist was
damals schon gerne hätte
denn dadurch kann er das dann später
diesen kommenden wahl vielleicht sogar
versuchen zu verschieben
diesen man traue ich alles zu ich muss
leider sagen
der kollege sagte wohin er hat
mitfühlende worte gehört diese man sagt
selber im partie ist etwas verloser er
ist ein mann der sagt gefühle darf ein
mann nicht ausdrücken man muss immer
hart bleiben
wie sein großer mentor wo ihn dabei
damals bei gewachsen man kann nichts
fühlen
er hat ein herz aus stahl er ist ein
schwarzes loch das sagt sogar seinen
engsten freunde die ihn kennen
ich glaube nicht dass er mein mitgefühl
ausdruck für den schwarzen gläsern
rassist tut mir leid bewiesen seine
ganze karriere schon in new york in
schweinberg wird das mutmasslich anders
sehen die frage ist bestätige vater ist
die situation den usa irgendwann mal
außer kontrolle gerät man hat ja kann
sich das gar nicht vorstellen dass eine
weltmacht wie die usa die ja schon
vieles durchstanden hat die auch sehr
robust als sehr robust gilt dass da
plötzlich diese eskalation in bislang
ungeahnte höhen treibt wo wir das
hinführen also ich würde ihnen gerne die
frage beantworten ich möchte aber paar
persönliche worte an den herrn williams
richten
also ich kenne sie nicht weil ich war
den usa als sie in deutschland eine
bekanntschaft errungen haben
aber ich muss eigentlich in erstmal sehr
danken für ihren service der südamerika
gemacht haben in diesem land als gi hier
in in europa sie haben großes geleistet
und
für usa und für europa in dem
amerikanischen in amerikanischen uniform
als hallodri nur 2 ich muss ihnen dazu
sagen dass ich als weiße natürlich nicht
nachvollziehen kann das was ein
schwarzer an rassismus beleidigungen und
sonstigen nachteilen
sowohl in usa wie aber auch hier in
europa fühlen kann das kann ich als
weiße nicht beurteilen
und von da aus haben sie meine größte
sympathie und obwohl ich selbst
natürlich kein rassist bin ich bin kein
antisemit ich bin auch kein schöner
vogel muss ich ihnen sagen ich kann mir
nur vorstellen was sie als schwarze
amerikaner oder schweizer bürger erleben
und da möchte ich mich auch bei ihnen
für diese hirnlose menschen die mit
denen sie konfrontiert waren während des
lebens stark entschuldigen und zu den
präsidenten gehe ich davon aus dass wir
darüber noch mal diskutieren werden sie
haben eine stimme in usa ich niemanden
dass sie nur amerikanische
staatsbürgerschaft behalten haben ich
habe eine stimme
und da können wir natürlich entscheiden
wer der bessere präsident wäre das
natürlich noch mitzureden
ich würde gerne noch drin wie gesagt
ihre meinung zu den protesten sind kann
das noch weiter eskalieren was man also
wir sehen schon jetzt dass es eine
beruhigung gibt es ist sehr bedauerlich
was da passiert ist auch der donald
trump hat gesagt dass er gegen
friedliche demonstranten gar nichts hat
das geht aber natürlich nicht dass
dort eigentum gestohlen wird und
vernichtet wird und diese paten haben
natürlich die friedlichen demonstranten
in okkupation genommen also war sie aber
es wird jetzt ruhiger also ich bin
irritiert sozusagen mit ihrem
berechtigten anliegen durch die
gewalttaten
ja also die gewalttaten sind das kann
man nicht entschuldigen
das sei dass das das geht nicht aber
natürlich jeder protest und jede
demonstration friedliche demonstration
in dieser situation ist muss ich mir
sicher richtig
was auffällt sind ja ist tatsächlich die
militanz dieser proteste das hat auch
eine gewisse tradition in den
vereinigten staaten sind wir unglaublich
968 austauschschülerinnen oder
studentinnen gewesen in den vereinigten
staaten
das war nach der ermordung von martin
luther king und von robert kennedy die
ja für einen ausgleich sorgen wollte
zwischen den rassen in den usa es gab da
im umfeld des demokratischen parteitags
in chicago
1968 gewaltige straßenschlachten ähnlich
wie jetzt woher kommt diese militanz ist
dass in den usa auch ausdruck einer
politischen auseinandersetzung ich meine
mir dringend sich auch die parallele auf
zu 1968 da war ich junge
austauschschülerin ist auch einer der
gründe warum ich dann
politikwissenschaft studiert habe
während ich das land begeistert hat
fasziniert hat ich habe in kalifornien
gelebt und zugleich diese gewalt die
attentate auf morgen das hacking und
dann auch auf robert kennedy im kurzen
zeitabstand voneinander
das habe ich als junge deutsche damals
als sehr sehr verstörend empfunden und
ich habe mir das damals dann auch so
erklärt es gibt ganz lange
auseinandersetzung gerade um die rassen
thematik in den usa und die
bürgerrechtsbewegung war ja nach dem
zweiten weltkrieg doch sehr stark
geworden 50er jahre 60er jahre und die
ermordung von martin luther king hatte
so eine immense symbolwirkung
es gab ja durchaus in den südstaaten
aber auch in den großen städten eine
organisierte schwarze
bürgerrechtsbewegung auch sehr stark
getragen durch die kirchen im übrigen
auch meinen dass er gegen war ja pastor
und insofern eine organisierte struktur
aber ich glaube es ist diese ungeduld
die wir heute auch wieder hören und es
ist ja auch erschreckend dass man 52
jahre nach 1968 immer noch über dieses
thema von rassismus und übermäßiger
polizeigewalt sprechen muss überhaupt wo
jetzt schon einen schwarzen us
präsidenten hat der das waren 68 kaum
denkbar ganz kurz und williams noch eine
ansgar graw die frage sie war neun jahre
korrespondent in den usa gewesen
diese militanz die von links aber auch
von rechts dort auftritt bei
demonstrationen die gibt es ja von
beiden politischen seiten ist die ein
spezielles innenpolitisches problem den
usa die sozusagen diese eskalation noch
weiter nach oben treibt ist das eine
besonders merkzeichen dieser situation
im moment unter trump na ja ich würde
sagen wir haben in den usa in den
letzten 20 jahren eine massive
polarisierung zwischen links und rechts
erlebt dass in ihm 100 an unter george
bush da waren schon die beiden lager
extrem weit auseinander gegangen jetzt
gegen kanada unter obama wurde es nicht
besser da war ganz am anfang also kammer
gewählt worden war gab es viel
zustimmung auch von von von
republikanern in der mitte aber
allmählich hat sich dann auch da wieder
gab dieser occupy wall street bewegung
also auch er hat sich amerika stark
auseinander entwickeln und das ist jetzt
unter donald trump noch einmal viel
härter geworden also es gibt es gab nie
ein präsident einen präsidenten der bei
dem anderen lager bei den demokraten so
wenig akzeptanz gefunden hat wie es doch
mit shampoo von hat insgesamt würde ich
ja die amerikaner verteidigung so
gewalttätig sind wie die politischen
debatten und die auseinandersetzung gar
nicht in aller regel stehen sich
demokraten und republikaner bei
irgendwelchen veranstaltungen gegenüber
freuen sich mit mit parolen und
schwenken plakate aber meistens kommt es
da nicht zu handgreiflichkeiten
jetzt bin ich aus von deutschen
demonstrationen oft schlimmeres gewöhnt
nur in dieser jetzigen situation wo sich
die beiden lager so verfestigt haben wo
es eben in der tat ist ron williams
gefragt donald trump ist jemand der von
seiner moralischen integrität alle
standards weit unterboten hatte er
ich sag jetzt mal polemisch aber
trotzdem sicher dass der sohn noch atme
so normal wie andere leute atmen
ja da ist einfach diese polarisierung so
weit vorangeschritten dass zwischenahn
extremisten so etwas ausnutzen und
extremisten sind es natürlich die jetzt
die berechtigten protest wegen des todes
von dort aus nutzen um nicht führt zu
demonstrieren sondern zu versuchen die
stadt kaputt zu schlagen von williams es
gibt ja ein vorwerfen donald trump er
würde das land spalten immer weiter
spalten wollen
das könnte allerdings ja auch für ihn
eine gefährliche strategie sein
natürlich ist es das aber ich möchte
kurz was anmerken
man muss natürlich die geschichte ein
bisschen weiter nach hinten aufdrehenden
am erker ist durch gewalt entstanden
man darf nicht vergessen wir vergessen
dass im ärger nur durch gewalt die
ureinwohner erledigt haben durch
sklaverei durch die die angriffe gegen
die irischen einwanderer america hat
eine starke tradition mit gewalt und da
die schwarzen immer diejenigen war die
das leider gottes die wenigen chancen
hatten hilfe zu bekommen durch gerichte
und dass die polizei immer seit
ewigkeiten würde ich das zurück desto
lauter hier stunden will ich erzählen
würde aber seit jahrzehnten seit seit
1816 119 haben schwarze seit der sklave
hier ankam nur mit gewalt vom weichen zu
tun gehabt hatte und leider gottes die
mehrheiten der schwarzen leider in den
südstaaten damals waren die opfer im
norden wo eine einigermaßen
einigermassen liberaler 1
durch die christliche einstellung von
denen leute die gegen straffrei waren
gab es eine eine gewisse an kleines
licht das vielleicht was da wird über
hamm linken natürlich war der präsident
der das irgendwie durchgesetzt natürlich
möglich machte aber die republikaner und
mein freund aus amerika muss ich sagen
wenn wir die tatsachen anschauen die
fakten war einer partei immer seit
roosevelt gegen gegen bremse angezogen
gegen wahlrecht gegen gleichberechtigung
gegen den bürgerrechtsbewegung war es
die republikaner und die demokraten
großenteils nicht alle waren dafür das
ist fakt wenn roosevelt war ja demokrat
gewesen
george weinberg haben die amerikaner es
versäumt ihre historischen hypotheken
die ron williams jetzt gerade aufgezählt
hat die vernichtung der indigenen
bevölkerung der indianer sklaverei und
so weiter haben die amerikaner diese
eigene geschichte zu wenig aufgearbeitet
dass es jetzt immer noch jahrhunderte
später zu diesen auseinandersetzungen
kommt also diese frage zu beantworten
warum wir dann mehrere stunden
ich kann nur auch auf europäische
geschichte verweisen auch die
[Musik]
kolonialherrschaft in der engländer der
holländer die kreuzzüge
das waren auch keine feine exempel eine
friedliche bewegung also diesen
einverstanden aber es geht jetzt um die
usa und die usa mit ihrer geschichte
umgeht
es ist das was der herr williams gerade
gesagt hat da ist absolut richtig also
das ist nun ein
ein schneller blick über die
amerikanische rassen geschichte dass da
hat er absolut recht
nur ich meine seit 68 hat sich in
amerika einiges
geändert und ich das gefühl oder dass
die die empfindung dass man auf
politischer administrativen wege dieses
alte unrecht wiedergutmachen will und
ich kann ihnen ganze menge beispiele
nennen wo man versucht die
benachteiligung der schwarze amerikaner
auszugleichen natürlich die die alte
schuld das kann man nicht ausgleichen
möchten sie die höheren von wir die die
die beispiele ein beispiel an den caroni
aliens darauf nochmal reagieren ja also
ich kann ihnen zum beispiel sagen dass
in meiner branche in der baubranche und
in der entwicklung war es in mehreren
states in amerika so dass wenn man
öffentliche aufträge haben wollte als
unternehmer bevorzugt waren unternehmen
wo ein afroamerikaner als partner war
und das war klar das heißt das hat sogar
auf dazu geführt dass man das auftrag
weges sich schnell sage ich mal ein
amerikanischen afroamerikaner als
partnerin gesucht hat in das unternehmen
etabliert hat um diesen öffentlichen
auftrag zu bekommen zweite beispiel ist
zum beispiel wenn es oben polizeichefs
gibt das wissen sie ja wenn es zwei
kandidaten gab einen weißen einen
schwarz amerikaner die die gleichen
qualität haben also die gleiche
diskussion hat man schon bevorzugt
absolut richtig in meiner meinung den
schwarzen kandidaten deswegen sehen sie
das in der amerikanischen polizei sehr
viele komisches sind afro-amerikaner
williams das war jetzt ein gegenargument
wurde sagen aber dank welche partei
welche politik es waren die demokraten
die immer das durchgesetzt haben die
bürgerrechtsbewegungen wurden von den
republikanern er regelmäßig zeit war ich
bin aus kalifornien morgen war meinen
kopf nur zweimal
er hat sehr stark von den sechziger
jahren immer gegen die bevor
der schwarzen im sinne von bürgerrechte
er war gegen den wahlrecht der schwarzen
er hat ungern den markt musik in
geburtstag wie sagt man diese
proklamation unterschrieben hat dagegen
die kämpfe bittet gekämpft er war kein
freund von dr er schätzt ihm gar nicht
und diese diese politik ist heute noch
in dieser partei präsent der
downloadshop diesen präsidenten leider
meinen auch diesen mann hatte new york
city als baulöwe als zweitklassige
schwarze nicht mal erlaubt sowohl bei
ihm die dürften keine miete zahlen und
keine wohnungen kaufen er wurde mit
immer wieder vor gericht gezogen das
wurde nie klar und deutlich ausgesagt
von ihrer partei warum wie kann man
einen ein mann mögen der in 1220 tage
18.000 mal gelogen hat sagt warum kann
man eine lüge an den peinlichen mensch
der sind amt nur besudelt überhaupt
respekt zollen tut mir leid ich bin da
wie die meisten schwarzen aufgewühlt
denn es dauert viel zu lang dass dieses
land dieses problem ins auge schaut es
ist seit es ist soweit und amerikaner
wollen es wissen die schwarzen sowie
viele weißenburg oder da denn die
amerikaner das wissen wollen spielen sie
jetzt auf die präsidentschaftswahlen an
im november wir sehen ja jetzt auch die
quasi die frontlinie in der
amerikanischen politik
damit sind wir auch beim wahlkampf der
gegner von einem stamm steht fest das
ist zu arbeiten er wird gegen ihn
antreten
er hat ja jetzt vorgestern eine rede
gehalten der zur versöhnung aufgerufen
wie übrigens auch der bruder des
getöteten george freut
er kann sich jetzt sozusagen als
alternativmodell aufbauen ist dass in
dieser situation für ihn von vorteil
ja von großem vorteil also man muss man
die beiden reden kontrastieren die rede
die donald trump im großen garten
gehalten hat bevor er dann diese diesem
fototermin mit der bibel wahrgenommen
hat und die rede von joe biden in
philadelphia und ich glaube da sieht man
zwei völlig verschiedene
persönlichkeiten aber auch zwei völlig
verschiedene politische
herangehensweisen und ich glaube dass
joe biden
erstens mit seiner verurteilung von
gewaltaktionen
so der die plünderungen und so weiter
die hat er verurteilt aber er hat
zugleich auch deutlich gemacht was
vorher herr graf auch schon sagte es ist
eine tief gespaltene gesellschaft und
zwar schon seit längerem
diese spaltung soll überwunden werden
denn es ist eigentlich auch sehr
unamerikanisch das amerikanische system
beruht darauf dass man sich verständigt
dass man bei gesetzesvorhaben auch über
parteigrenzen hinweg eine vernünftige
lösung versucht zu finden das hat er
sehr stark gemacht und insofern war
natürlich seine präsentation glaube ich
der situation sehr angemessen die frage
ist kann er das momentum bis zum
november auch wirklich durchhalten
er hat prominente unterstützer und
unterstützerinnen es gibt auch eine sehr
aktive parteibasis bei den demokraten
im moment ist das alles durch corona
sehr eingeschränkt was er machen kann
ein wahlkampf aber auch wenn das
gelockert wird und wenn im september
dann also auch veranstaltungen
stattfinden können
dann ist die frage kann er dieses
momentum wirklich zu seinen gunsten
nutzen die umfragen sind gut für ihn
aber das reicht ja nicht aus wie wir aus
dem wahlkampf 2016
und wie gesagt dann wieder die umfragen
gewinnen sondern die wahlen die
amerikaner ansgar graw haben ganz
bestimmt nicht die qual der wahl am
dritten november zwischen den beiden
dass daum sind wie wird sich dieses
duell jetzt weiterentwickeln
wer hat da im moment vorteile doch ist
nicht klar wer gibt keinen eindeutigen
favoriten was glauben sie wie sich das
jetzt entwickeln wird der wird sich
weiter zuspitzen manche reden ja sogar
schon vom schmutzigsten wahlkampf in der
us geschichte
wobei man in jedem wahlkampf in amerika
davon inzwischen vom schmutzigsten
wahlkampf sprich das auch so ein
bisschen der amerikanischen nach
superlativen geschuldet der nächste ist
dann noch schmutziger aber er wird
natürlich schmutzig tram klammert sich
an sein amt und diese befürchtung die
neben schon einmal geäußert wurde wird
er überhaupt konzipiert über auf
einräumen wenn er verlieren sollte im
november ich glaube er wird es nicht
schaffen die wahl zu verlieren
zu verschieben entschuldigung dass wir
da nicht schaffen das ist in den usa
ausgesprochen schwierig da müsste der
gesamte müssen beide kammern des
kongresses mitmachen das werden die
demokraten sicherlich nicht tun da muss
man wirklich was weiß ich eine ganz
wichtige corona welle noch einmal kommen
und er versuche jetzt schon die
briefwahl zu delegitimieren und als als
betrugsanfällig darzustellen im moment
führt joe biden und das entscheidende
ist dass er nicht nur in den national
konzentrations seiten umfragen führt
sondern eher für die nahezu jedem fast
nicht in allen aber in fast jedem der 50
bundesstaaten und vor allen dingen auch
in der entscheidenden states die im
vergangenen vier jahren dafür gesorgt
haben dass kilometern am schluss im
grunde mit 30.000 stimmen in den
entscheidenden den wichtigen staaten
industriegebiet verloren hat obwohl sie
us-weit fast drei millionen stimmen mehr
bekommen hatte als schaue ich glaube
diesmal wird es für thür beiden darum
reichen aber was ich schon am anfang
sagte er braucht bestimmte wählergruppen
und er brauchte unter anderem die
schwarzen und die muss er jetzt
einerseits den muss er bestätigen dass
er auf ihrer seite steht aber er darf
dadurch nicht weiter abschrecken die
alle die legitimität dieses protestes
anerkennung es gab gerade eine umfrage
heute von reuters 68 prozent stimmen
überein mit dem anliegen der
demonstranten 68 prozent aber
gleichzeitig haben viele dieser
amerikanischen bürger angst werde dass
dieser protest inzwischen von
gewalttätern kopiert wird wie es ja eben
auch schon angesprochen wurde
und da muss eben joe biden die richtige
schlangenlinie dazwischen finden dass er
nicht als sympathisant der der
gewalttäter erscheint und dann glaube
ich wird er es schaffen so schweinberger
es gibt ja mein vorwurf von manchen
leuten an sonne samt der würde gar nicht
akzeptieren wenn er die wahl verlieren
wird
als sie das für denkbar dass er nach
einer verlorenen wahl das in zweifel
ziehen dass die wahl korrekt war eine
demokratische wahl ist ja ein
wesentliches element eines
demokratischen staates
gut also dass sind wieder diese viele
forderung von beruf hier irgendwie war
eine frage
frage also ja auch hätte überhaupt keine
basis haben und ich möchte nur frau
professor jörg darauf hinweisen bei
aller begeisterung für deinen beiden der
beiden war vice president acht jahre
unter obama einen schwarzen präsidenten
in dieser zeit hat beiden für die
schwarzen gar nichts gemacht ganz im
gegenteil hat sehr viel für sich gemacht
für seinen sohn der aus usa aus china
anderthalb milliarden dollar für seinen
turm geholt hat für seinen sohn sehr
dort bei einer ukrainischen firma 1
millionen job bekommen hat und vor
kurzem der gleiche beiden wir haben sich
ob sie das gehört haben bei einem
radiointerview bei einem radiointerview
wo der schwarze reporter in eine frage
gestellt hat hat eine rassistische
äußerung gemacht und erlauben sie mir
herr böhme ist dass ich in etwas gerade
zu den sie können es nicht hören
sie wollen nicht hören aber lassen wir
zusammen donald trump ihren schwarzen
amerikaner mehr gemacht hat als obama in
den acht jahren denken sie an die
justizreform wo mehrere schwarze leute
ausgibt aus dem gefängnis raus gekommen
denken sie bitte an die
sie performt 800 milliarden dollar in
benachteiligte stadtviertel von usa
investiert werden wo die schwarzen
amerikaner leben und bitte vergessen
sondern auch etwas nicht dass fünf
millionen schwarze amerikaner sind von
den footsteps befreit worden haben jobs
bekommen die arbeitslosigkeit immer mehr
unter tragen war 3,8 prozent bis
natürlich diese woche wer diese virus
gekommen ist das alles möchten sie bitte
vielleicht zu kennen ist nicht will ich
nicht akzeptieren
aber das sind fakten und dieser
daraufhin reiter sehr die
präsidentschaftskandidaten beiden und
jump im september und oktober insgesamt
drei duelle im fernsehen machen werden
wir wenn jetzt hier das ist nicht
vorziehen aber ich gebe gerne ron
williams noch mal das wort auf diese
vorhaltungen zu antworten möchte als
gegenargument mehr mister weinberg ich
musste lachen vorhin als ich ihre ihre
gehört habe entschuldigung aber momentan
einrichtungen in afrika und in ihren
kernregionen fax man kann seine eigene
man kann seine eigene meinung haben aber
keine eigene fakten
obama hatte sogar mehr arbeitsplätze als
webshop reicht aber das ist nicht so
wichtig entschuldigung diesem
präsidenten hat uns schwarzen nichts
gemacht er hat gar nichts gemacht und
deshalb ist die mehrheit nicht für
rentrop
deshalb ist er mehrheit für einen beigen
und immer für die demokraten nicht dass
die demokraten immer richtig gehandelt
haben oder fehler gemacht haben herr
obama hat natürlich alles dahin bekommen
was er wollte
aber immerhin war die richtung richtig
wer hat gebremst dann kommst du marcano
müsste über lindsay graham diese rechte
republikanische konservativen die nichts
wollten anders als diesen präsidenten
auszubremsen herr obama hatte kein glück
im ersten amtszeit war warum weil ihre
partei hat gesagt handbremse er darauf
gar nichts erreichen worte vermisste
marcano persönlich das wissen sie doch
dass alte doch ehrlich hier wir wissen
ganz genau dass die rechten in merka
nicht für uns in schwarzen
wahlrecht sind die kämpfe dagegen zeit
den seit den 40er jahren hallo nur zur
erklärung es natürlich beim namen
genannt
der mehrheitsführer der republikaner und
der obama da waren die wertverhältnisse
anders in repräsentantenhaus und senat
und das hat obama das leben schwer
gemacht ist allerdings auch bestandteil
der amerikanischen checks and balances
das heißt also das war die macht auch
verteilt ist dass einer nicht so viel
macht hat konnte jetzt zu der aktuellen
situation auch man hat ja donald trump
immer vorgeworfen werde auch in sachen
corona und pandemie falsch reagiert die
wirtschaft ist auf talfahrt über 40
millionen arbeitslose eine
unvorstellbare zahl auf wenn man das
vergleicht mit deutschland in
deutschland leben weniger menschen aber
dann ist so eine riesige zahl von
menschen jetzt arbeitslos sind ist eine
grosse hypothek für donald trump ja also
auf jeden fall denn er hat ja immer
wieder betont dass er die wirtschaft
richtig gut ins laufen gebracht hat und
wenn sie mich im januar gefragt hätten
ja natürlich
arbeitslosigkeit ist gesunken es gab
mehr jobs und so weiter nur in der
jetzigen situation ist das eine sehr
schwere hypothek für donald trump und
ich habe eigentlich noch nicht genau
wahrgenommen welches programm er jetzt
entwickelt außer eben die den lockdown
möglichst schnell zu beenden damit alle
wieder anfangen können zu arbeiten aber
so einfach wird das nicht gehen er führt
gleichzeitig ein handelskrieg mit china
viele der jobs werden so nicht schnell
wieder zurückkommen dass wir dauernd 41
millionen arbeitslose sind für die usa
eine zahl das ist also höher als in der
großen depression in den 30er jahren
sehr schwierig für wen immer wer im
weißen haus sitzt ob das donald trump
dann ist im nächsten jahr oder joe biden
eine sehr schwere hypothek für donald
trump ganz besonders weil das immer
seine sein markenzeichen war ich bin
unternehmer ich weiß wie es geht
die wirtschaft läuft und nun kann man
ihm nicht vorwerfen dass die pandemie
eben dazu geführt hat dass diese
betriebe alle schließen geschlossen
haben und so weiter
aber wie gesagt also ich sehe kein
konzept von ihm außer dass man ein
riesiges rettungspaket jetzt im kongress
verabschiedet hat das ist ja bei uns in
deutschland ähnlich
das zweite paket klemmt also dass da
blockieren auch die republikaner waren
man nicht genau weiß wer kriegt jetzt
welche beträge also die hypothek für den
kampf ist sehr hoch und das ist auch
einer der gründe weshalb ich glaube dass
eher schwer haben wird er kann natürlich
im herbst sagen es geht wieder aufwärts
und es kommt ja eher darauf an was die
menschen glauben was passiert und nicht
so sehr wie die börsenkurse sind ja oder
wie jetzt irgendwelche makroökonomischen
daten sich entwickeln sondern was
glauben die menschen trauen sie ihm zu
dass er das schiff wieder flott macht
oder hat joe biden und die demokratische
parteien besseres konzept mit dem sie
mehr leute überzeugen können und nicht
nur die afroamerikaner also ich meine es
ist eine wichtige wählergruppe aber sie
machen nur zwölf prozent der bevölkerung
aus es geht auch um viele viele andere
die überzeugt werden müssen von beiden
kandidaten also gerade unter frauen ist
die kritik an donald trump sehr hoch
also es gibt keine gruppe altersgruppe
soziale gruppe von frauen mehr die
donald trump noch unterstützt sondern
alle unterstützen mehrheitlich beiden
zurzeit wichtige gruppe sind die
hispanics also es gibt mehrere
wählergruppen die angesprochen werden
müssen
ansgar graw bislang haben wir immer
geglaubt dass die amerikaner ist etwas
gelassener sehen mit der wesentlich
geringeren sozialen sicherheit in den
usa als zb in deutschland wenn man sich
jetzt diese riesige zahl von
arbeitslosen ansieht und auch nicht
genau weiß wann es mit der wirtschaft
wieder bergauf geht ist das etwas was
donald trump gerade jetzt im wahlkampf
auch auf die füße fallen kann
ja das ist für ihn deswegen schwierig
weil sich der das amerikanische
selbstverständnis da hat mich verändert
hat und weiterhin verändern sagt das ja
auch die amerikanische nation nicht
minder durch migration wanderung gerade
durch ist reinigt für die klassischen
weißen amerikaner war im hardcover
meinen der große straße ist ein bisher
ein abschreckendes für viele sind
amerikaner die zwischen zugewandert sind
und auch für die schwarzen jetzt die
coverband kein feindbild sondern eher
verheißung und darum ist
gerade in einer phase in die wir jetzt
eintreten werden mit diesen vielen
arbeitslosen ist für trump ausgesprochen
schwierig dann zu sagen ich als
derjenige der bisher immer gesagt hat
dass unternehmer schaffen alles dann
aber selber ja sehr schwierig ist die
sprache wohl in seiner außenpolitik in
seinem außenhandel in seinem
protektionismus
aber da ist ist es schwierig sein
eigenes image und seine politik
einerseits bekommt ich würde doch ein
wort ganz gerne sagen dazu zur
legislatur von barack obama ich finde
barack obama war schon deswegen ein
großartiger präsident war das sind acht
jahren obama im weißen haus keinen
einzigen persönlichen skandal gegeben
hatte ist also eine wirklich integere
figur aber seine politik hat natürlich
auch viele schwächen gehabt
ausgesprochen viele er hat am anfang als
die als er gesagt hat ich mache jetzt
obamacare ich mache die
gesundheitsreform das sind die
republikaner auf sie zugegangen haben
gesagt herr präsident wir haben
lena war das damals ich habe hier ein
paar vorschläge und da hatte obama
gesagt eure vorschläge interessieren
mich nicht
wir haben gewonnen die das gewinn einer
wahl muss sich lohnen wir haben unser
eigenes konzept wir wollen gar kein
kompromiss suchen
das war sicherlich ein fehler herbst in
den ersten zwei jahren seiner amtszeit
er hatte ja obama im kongress beide
kammern senat und repräsentantenhaus die
mehrheit für die demokraten
trotzdem hat er außer obamacare nicht
besonders viel zuwege gebracht
beispielsweise verschärfung der
waffengesetze oder so etwas darum so ein
ganz großartiger präsident war obama im
rückblick nicht er war ein sehr
sympathischer präsident einst völlig
spanischen liga präsident das
unterscheidet die massiv von sharp und
gerade deswegen glaube ich wäre dieser
mangel wegen dieses mangels an
integrität der jetzt auch sichtbar wird
im umgang mit der mit den akteuren
fehlte wohl corona wo er das zu lange
geleugnet hat und dann aber jetzt auch
mit dem tod von gott floyd diese dieser
mangel an integrität den können jetzt
auch die meisten fans von jump nicht
mehr übersehen und dass wir ihnen
politisch das genick brechen
möglicherweise nutzt es dort haben wir
wenig dass auch barack obama fehler
gemacht hat als präsident wenn es jetzt
so bleibt vor allem mit der hohen zahl
von aber
loosen den usa es gibt dort kein
kurzarbeitergeld wie hier wo man das zum
teil auch aufhören kann auch die
arbeitslosenunterstützung ist sehr viel
geringer muss donald trump dann mehr
soziale kompetenz man könnte es ja auch
soziales gewissen nennen zeigen um die
wahl noch zu gewinnen im november also
ich komme gerne auf ihre frage das ist
eine gute frage aber ich möchte frau
lemke jetzt massiv widersprechen
ich bin die letzten vier monate den usa
gewesen bin jetzt zwei wochen zurück aus
flora gekommen ich habe jeden briefing
von präsident trump mir angeschaut das
war täglichen briefings waren das um 6
uhr ortszeit sollen hat die krise hat
voran gemanagt er hat geschafft dass
sowohl militär aber auch
gesundheitsexperten wie doktor brix und
octopussy bei jeder pressekonferenz
dabei waren und fachlich ihn beraten
konnten
er hat geschafft dass ford und gm in
kürzester zeit die ventilators
hergestellt haben die praktisch für
jedes krankenhaus in amerika verfügbar
waren
wir haben jetzt mit lehrer lehrgang
obama auch von obama geerbt es war gar
nichts und übrigens diese krise
als ihm in die schuhe schieben das in
amerika 30 millionen und 40 millionen
arbeitslose gibt das glaube ich kann ja
gesagt das ist ja der korona geschuldet
ich habe nicht mehr so viel zeit meine
frage nach der frage ja ja gut die
sozialkomponente konsistenz des
präsidenten jetzt brauchten die wahl zu
gewinnen
also es gibt es sechs jeder haben wir
also es gibt es natürlich in amerika
werden die schecks jetzt verschickt an
leute die ihre jobs verloren haben
durch die korona krise da orientiert man
sich an den an der steuereinkommen an
die steuereinkommen der bestimmten
amerikaner und ich weiß nicht ob sie
einen schreck bekommen haben aber viele
viele amerikaner haben monatliche chefs
bekommen die höher sind sogar als ihr
hoffentlich arbeitslohn was auch zu
gewissen problem mittlerweile führt also
übrigens die statistiken über die
wahlchancen von donald trump da kann ich
nur verweisen an die alten prognosen
ich bin ich glaube nicht an diese wer
lust hat kann er darauf wetten wenn er
will
kurz bitteschön
wir haben gesehen wie doch der vc und
doch der berg von shampoos sei derjenige
der jetzt auch kein gehäuse sagen dürfen
öffentlich jawohl virologisch sondern
diesen präsident durch seinen
inkompetenz durch seine späte reaktion
überhaupt auf dieser virus damals es
gibt keine es wird wie schnell weg gehen
wir nicht sonne rauskommt glaubt mir es
ist schauen wir die videos anhören wir
seine worte an
der mann ist selbst der beweis dass er
in kompetent ist der song ist kann mit
seinen infantilen brötchen die er von
sich gibt bei jeder pressekonferenz für
sein nennt pressekonferenz wenn ein
reporter einer schwierigen frage stellt
chinas ist die fitness und wie ein
kleines kind stammte weg das ist kein
präsident das ist ein infantiles kind
das ist der kaiser doppelt der erste der
völlig nackt dasteht und wir sind
entsetzt denn es ist widerlich was wir
da sehen diesen mann gehört weit weg von
weißen haus eigentlich vor gericht in
new york in sachen wichtig und das wird
passieren wenn er diesen amt verlieren
deshalb kämpft er weil er weiß er muss
vor den kadi
wenn er nach hause kommt dass
privatmensch reaktion eine propaganda
fox news ist auch sogar bitte hat es ist
peinlich sind es 30 sekunden der
entgegnung noch hin und reden ich würde
gern die schlussrunde dann ein lloyd
also es gibt momentan einem verfahren
gegen obama massiv behindert hat die
wahl von dem präsidenten krampf er hat
die fbi und cia korrumpiert zusammen
und jetzt kommen die löcher beweise auch
die ehemalige ehemalige botschafterin in
berlin ist jetzt damit beauftragt worden
diesen sprachen diesen
belastungsmaterial tag seiner nirvana
aufzuholen das ist sehr gut okay
vielleicht sind das ja auch da auch
einige verschwörungstheorien dabei von
professor lembke
es hätte ja auch die usa - moderator der
herr wie gesagt wir sind noch nicht eben
präsidenten duell hier sondern versuchen
die amerikanische politik amerikanische
politik sie beide als platzhalter die
amerikanische politik dem deutschen
fernsehzuschauer nahe zu bringen
das als technologischer spitzenreiter in
vielen bereichen und leistet sich ein
ein soziales dilemma in den unteren
gesellschaftsschichten
bisher war das land robust genug das
auszuhalten diese gegensätze zwischen
denen die wenig die habenichtse und die
die viel haben die usa diesen spagat
auch weiterhin schaffen also ich glaube
dass die korona pandemie nochmal anstoß
gibt um über das gesundheitssystem
gründlich nachzudenken
weil es ja nicht nur kritik gibt an den
unversicherten sondern es gibt eben auch
kritik an vorsorge an gesundheits
versorgung in ländlichen gebieten oder
auch in ballungsgebieten mit sozial mit
ärmeren schichten das wird ein großes
thema bildungswesen ist natürlich auch
die große frage ob man so eine
hochtechnologie ein so innovatives land
wird in die zukunft auch weiter
fortsetzen können wenn das
bildungssystem eigentlich nicht wirklich
das liefert was liefern sollte nämlich
eine breite gute allgemeinbildung aus
der dann eben auch begabte und
innovationsfreudige nachwuchskräfte
hervorgehen das sind also dinge in denen
ich in der zukunft auch sehr viel
sprengstoff sehe
ansgar graw letzte frage wie die kurze
antwort die frage in der der titel der
sendung lautete scheitert oder
profitiert trump wenn ich sie richtig
verstanden habe im moment wird er
scheitern moment wird er scheitern aber
ich stimme an der stelle so dass wir auf
prognosen nicht zu viele setzen sollten
weil wir uns da 2016 bei der
präsidentschaftswahl auch tüchtig gegner
dann trotzdem glaube ich für krank wird
es entscheidend sein
er müsste jetzt ein neues momentum
bekommen er müsste jetzt eine
erfolgsgeschichte erzählen können
bis zum november dass er geschafft hat
und da sehe ich im moment wegen corona
und wegen dieser nicht wirklich
geführten debatte über polizeigewalt
weil ihm kein ansatz war wirklich ein
gewinnerthema für sich finden
das wären ja genau im blick behalten ich
bedanke mich dass sie da waren danke an
ron williams ansgar graw professor
franke und anshu jain wird bleiben sie
bei uns
[Musik]